hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
y'all really liked the last code with me
video so
we're doing another one
yay i don't know what it was about the
other one
maybe it's because you all saw me
struggling and it helped with your
imposter syndrome
or hopefully it was just entertaining i
don't know
let me know in the comments down below
what you liked about it but we're doing
it again
because i had like an hour or so and i
figured why not use this time to again
code for fun we're gonna code again on
the lumicube and
last time i asked what i should make
this coming time and someone suggested
which is rock paper scissors in japanese
and i thought it could be fun
and uh if at the end i could go against
it
best out of five and see who wins
it's me against the machine it's humans
against not
ai but against this little cute
cube that i have by the way i'm going to
be coding on this thing which is a lumi
cube it runs on raspberry pi
it runs using python and it's just the
easiest way to get set up and i'm also
terrible at python
so i thought it could be fun as you
watch me
try to figure out what the heck i'm
doing but
i think because i made the thing last
time hopefully it'll be easier because i
still do remember some key moments and
some key syntax
that i probably should have known
beforehand but that's okay
we live and learn so here's another
little montage to show you how things go
yo my brain my brain's not ready for
coding right now
why isn't it working
i don't what i think i broke it
i'm a genius so if that at all interests
you then stick around
okay shall we get started
okay so my plan is to have like a
countdown
i don't know if it can take japanese but
i was gonna have it go
and then on pong there's gonna be like
like representations i don't know if i'm
gonna make like representations of like
rock
paper scissors we'll see we'll see
i think i'll probably do the easy thing
first of just writing down the words so
that i can get the logic
correct and then we'll work on
the cute prettiness maybe i can even get
it to do sound i don't know we'll see
so starting with a clean slate here
heck how do you do this again how
how do you do this again um
um
wow we're off to a great start everybody
oh
the code was sitting in front of me this
whole time i guess
there's buttons on the back of this
there's these buttons
it goes from like one to zero
oh if top pressed equals one i think
probably so if it's on oh it's like
literally like a switch
duh come on moyuko you've coded before
invalid syntax invalid
how do you do coding how do you do
how do you do the code my brain is still
sleepy i gotta i gotta warm up a little
bit
okay okay okay
so next what i'm gonna do
is check my cheat sheet
so i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna copy a lot of these
um that are equal to zero
oh wait i don't need brackets because
this is python
which i learned from a lot of y'all is a
name i believe it's a tur it's
i think people said it's a turkish name
so that's cool
if any of y'all are turkish hello
okay so if buttons top press mod 2
equals 0
then seconds i have five seconds
i have red red red than red great let's
do green
yellow red
okay does that work okay ready
ready where the heck is the button
no bad okay okay oh
what are you doing what are you doing
what what
it's just going through junk and boom
forever what are you doing
it's repeating forever is it because
it's in a while loop forever
hello director
oh okay i think i know why because it
after this exits buttons pressed count
is still mod 2 so then it just goes here
i see
[Music]
okay
is there a thing that's like only do
things
when the button is pressed once you know
what i mean
no i think i feel like top pressed if
top pressed is equal to one right
will it do that
four three two one
oh i did it wait why didn't it work
before
i don't get it but that's fine
that's fine it's cool
it's totally cool all right that's what
i did
that's what i did scroll text
scroll text
uh ready
oh can i do japanese yo
green i guess
okay can you do you know japanese little
guy
nope nope nope probably not
it doesn't know japanese my cube is not
bilingual like me
i guess it's ready ready
ready zhang
is that too slow
three three
two one zero
it's gonna be fast this time ready
okay that's i think that's better okay
it's time for a quick bio break while
i'll tell you about the sponsor of
today's video career karma
so some of you are probably looking to
do a career switch into tech
and you might know that boot camps are
the quickest and easiest way to do so
and if you're interested in boot camps
really just getting into the tech
industry at all then
you should be on career karma korea
karma is the easiest place to find a
us-based
job training program online they help
over 1 million workers navigate their
careers
every month offering support through a
community of peers
mentors and coaches to find your dream
career
they have a ton of resources like
amazing blog posts and reviews about
different coding bootcamps
and also live audio rooms led by coaches
and mentors to give you
advice to switch into tech also the best
part is that korea karma is free and it
always will be
so because you're sponsoring today's
video the first 1000 of my subscribers
get exclusive access to free coaching
sessions
with career karma coaches that will
jumpstart your tech career
so make sure to go to ck.chat myuco to
learn more
thank you again so much to career
commerce for sponsoring today's video
hopefully y'all are hydrated by now
and so now let's get back to the video
okay so i got that
import random
um and then on the poem random.0012
cube.scroll text
paw i could just do rock paper scissors
fam
but they asked for someone asked for
junk
and why not learn how to
do rock paper scissors in a different
language for all of you who don't speak
japanese this is a cultural experience
okay okay mvp
mvp ready ready
i lost it kind of works but the timing
is super
not obvious
pretty happy with the mvp it's got to be
better
i think we got to figure out a better
thing than the scroll text business
speaker oh
let's try it oh my gosh it's going to
speak to me
let's just see what this does what if
it's really weird
i didn't know that my cube had a male
voice but
cool i think just like a stoplight thing
is not a bad idea
you know what i mean cube dot set all
green yellow
and then red basically it's an
experiment we're always gonna experiment
if you're coding but not experimenting
gotta experiment okay
it'll go ready
oh that's way better
i'm a genius okay
should i do a bit representation
an eight by i think it's eight by eight
seven by seven representation of gu
okay okay so how can i make
a freaking go goo is the easiest it
looks like this
i guess
like this does that look like a good
i don't think i don't think that looks
very good
sure
so let's try the paw because that'll be
easier i don't know
these are mickey hands
this is going to be the hard one it's
going to be incredibly hard
these are my artistic renditions of
so how can i
convert this into code
ease set panel color array
yeah i can do that black
let's see what it looks like
oh look at that i did it
now i think i can get through everything
so please hold while i brute force
things
okay all right now that it works
now that it works we're gonna do me
against the machine
best out of five ready
i win one for muco
two vermuco one more to win it
oh machine one one
aiko that's ty
come on
i win i did
it i did it i beat you the thing i made
but it could very well beat me too if i
wasn't lucky
hey that's fun i did it everybody yay
well hey thank you all for watching
today's video i hope you liked it
i had fun now i have a little friend
that i can play with whenever i feel
like
i'm gonna leave links to the source code
as well as
the lumi cube in the description box
down below if you want to see
more of these videos let me know what
you'd like for me to
do i guess whether that be another lumi
cube app
or maybe it's an ios app i would love
your ideas put them in the comments down
below don't forget to subscribe and i
will see you next time
bye